an arrest that's turned into a political
crisis tunisia's former justice minister
nuridin al-bahidi is in hospital after
being detained last week he's fighting
for his life after refusing to eat or
take his medicines for a week
wife
says she supports what he's doing and is
joining him
yes hunger strike with him either we
leave together and he goes home or let
them take us both in a coffin his
supporters say he's a victim of an abuse
of the justice system that may have
serious consequences
the life of mr nourodine
lawyer deputy former minister of justice
and the leader of a political party that
is recognized in the country is in real
danger
bahadi was arrested on friday on what
the government calls terror offenses
accused of illegally handing out
official falsified documents the
interior minister says he had to act to
preserve national security
this is a matter of creating and
delivering nationality certificates and
passports in an illegal way to people
whom i will not mention
deputy chairman of enada the largest
political party in the suspended
parliament it was dismissed in july by
president kai saeed who has since ruled
by decree while promising political
reform
a sharp critic of the president and his
power grab bahadi has accused saeed of
declaring himself king
tunisia was seen as a success story of
the arab springs call for greater
democracy but human rights groups say
the country is lurching back towards
dictatorship andrew chappelle al jazeera